hi everybody this is peter cooper from
the ncbi welcome to today's webinar
i'll go ahead and turn this over to mike
fiolo mike take it away
thanks peter thank you all for taking
the time to join today i know you are
all very busy
today's webinar is dbgap submission
improvements and gaap tools
the webinar agenda uh first i'll give a
little bit of a background of dbgap for
those of you who are new to tbgap um
then i want to talk about some of the
submission improvements specifically the
study data outlines study configuration
and sequence metadata upload that we've
introduced in the last 18 months or so
and then talk about our software tool
um called gap tools
some of the current features and
dale will do a software demo
and then we can have a q a afterwards
so for those of you who are new to dbgap
dbgap is a permanent archive of
genetic data produced in
research studies it provides versioned
release of the data for other
researchers to access
um it has two
two modes one is a public metadata mode
and a controlled access mode for
individual level
controlled data
um
the anatomy of a dbgap um
data set first of all our high level
data model
object is called a dbgap study
and this consists of
study metadata
which has
information about the study and then
public documents and these are documents
that don't
that are used within the study like
questionnaires or research protocols
and then we have a controlled access
mode for the for the data that involves
phenotypic data um
genotype data called genotypes sequence
data
medical images and association analysis
and all of these controlled access items
also have metadata information that can
be public as well
a research study is data collected from
the same funding
or research focus or cohort
that's loosely defined
today we do want to talk about some of
the improvements we've made to uh
the data submission part of our process
um as many of you may know
and for those who don't
there's a study registration step um
involved with dbgap and that's because
we have the controlled access data
and this this step largely involves the
the principal investigator and their
team
and the
nih genomic program administrators
are registering the study and
configuring the certification
for for releasing the data and then
then there's a
a part of the process where the data is
actually submitted to dbgap and that's
where my team
gets involved and today we're going to
talk about
some of the improvements we've made here
um
so
one improvement that we've made and this
is to reduce the iterations that we have
often
when we have submitters
submissions um
although the study may be registered
with a certain data configuration we
don't always know for a specific version
what data will be coming in so to avoid
having to ask that question
we ask that the submitter fill out a um
study data outline
and this this is the the submitter's
assertion of what data will be included
in that version of the study
um this informs specifically what what
the curator should expect so that we
know that we have the data that you
intend to submit
and um
it also allows the submitter to see how
the study was uh registered because they
may not necessarily be involved in that
stuff
and um
because it collects the information that
are typically
needed by the
curators it reduces the need to ask
common questions and to follow up later
through email
next i want to talk about
this study configuration web form
this is uh
how we collect our
study metadata
and previously for those of you who have
submitted
in the past
um this was collected through a word
document that was uploaded to the
website
we've now replaced that word doc with a
web-based
rich text form that allows you to
to enter all the information that was
previously entered in the word document
to the site directly
and this this improvement actually
provides a way for the study a session
to be assigned
uh as soon as the
submitter is engaged with dbgap and it
also allows a public
preview of the public page
right after the form is completed
the third third improvement that i'd
like to talk about
on the submission uh process is the
sequence metadata upload
and previously um
the
sequence uh upload to dbgap because it's
handled through another team called sra
at ncbi this was often done through
emails
um
that were were arranged by the curators
at the time of submission
but now we've kind of started to
incorporate the sequence metadata upload
through
an automated email that are that sent to
the submitter as soon as the samples are
loaded
and um
as long as there's sequence data
expected in the study data outline
the upload is just
through our upload page there's a new
section called sequence metadata
and that's where the files are uploaded
and uh this file is unlike uh some of
the other files that are uploaded to
gpgap submission portal is downloadable
so that others
in the research study can can access it
as well to see what samples
are are loaded within this
sequence metadata
this is a first step to automating the
sequence upload and processing in dbgap
we weren't able to do it all in one step
but i wanted to let you know that's
where we're headed
next i'd like to focus more on once we
get
the data files
what
we do to process them
and that involves
a tool called gap tools but before i do
that i do want to step back a little bit
because i know that there's some people
on the on the call that may not have
submitted to dbgap yet or are involved
in the in the registration phase and i
just wanted to go over
uh at a high level kind of the
relational
model that we have in dbgap and the
identifiers that are very important
so we have two core files that are
necessary for submission to db for most
dbgap studies
and this is the subject consent file
which lists it's a master list of the
subjects within the study
um
and the uh consent of that subject and
uh
the
the consent
is the orderable unit within dbgap and
then there's a subject sample mapping
file
which is the explicit list of samples
from each subject
and so these ids are very important in
the dbgap model
there's a set of um phenotype files any
number of them
that can be submitted along with
the core files
and this this includes any number of
measured traits and it can be any number
of files
and so in this way along with the data
set
uh with the data there's a data
dictionary associated to all our data
sets that are submitted on the phenotype
side
that allow us to configure
uh any number of traits for a person
uh
next
next we have uh
what we call
the pedigree file the pedigree file is
only necessary when there's related
people within the study
um this this file represents the
relationships of the subjects to each
other
we also have a file called this sample
attributes file and this allows you to
include any number of attributes for a
sample
the relationship of these files are
the subject phenotype and pedigree files
are related back to
the subject consent file
through the subject id
and the sample attributes file is
related back to the subject sample
mapping file through this through the
sample id
likewise the sample ids are expected to
be into the molecular data both both
called genotypes
any kind of omics data and sequence data
we also uh
require that the sex of the individuals
should match in all the files and that
includes the phenotype and the genotype
files
um
now i'd like to talk about gap tools and
um
what it is it's it's a it's a validation
software that we've developed
uh
to operate on the dbgap formatted files
the current input is the subject consent
subject sample mapping file pedigree
file subject phenotype sample attributes
called genotypes in both plink and vcf
formats
um this tool operates on all or a subset
of these files
and
the tool outputs qc results
uh some metrics and logging and some
some reports
if you have questions about specifics on
this the
the files within dbgap you can go to our
submission guide and the link is here
more about dbgap
tools the current output uh
returns specific errors and warnings of
the validation um
and
so
some of the
categories
of errors and warnings are file format
data set to data dictionary matching
subject and sample id matching across
files
and variable naming
and the geno sex and relationships to
the phenotypic data
and then we have this that we have two
reports that are reported out through
the pipeline
when appropriate
the genetic relationship and the x
chromosome sex determination
as computed by the tool
so you know there is two validation
modes for dbgap tools one is we run this
tool internally on the files that you
submit to dbgap through our submission
portal it's it's as of this year it's
fully integrated with submission portal
so when you upload files
it will run on all
eligible dbgap submissions
um
what the when the tool is run an
automated uh email of the results is
then sent to the submitter
and this tool also within the pipeline
internal pipeline compares the
previously submitted files if they
haven't been deleted from the submission
uh this allows us to do uh continuity
across versions
um
but this tool also can be run in a
standalone mode um it's set up as a
docker container which is click and
cloud ready
um
it validates files prior to submission
and this is the purpose of this is to
reduce iterations with dbgap you don't
have to submit the files you can check
them yourself if if you're so inclined
it is a little bit technical
um but it does run the same initials qc
check says dbgap now we do have a manual
curation
pipeline that is
more expansive
than this tool
but we are building out the tool to
include what we can automatically
um now i'd like to
transition over and allow uh
software engineer dale conklin to
show a demo of gap tools
hello this is dale conklin with the
national center for biotechnology
information which is part of the
national library of medicine at nih
i'm on the software development team and
have developed
with my team a tool that essentially
takes the validation pipeline for dbgap
submissions and makes it externally
available for anybody to download
the place to get started with this is to
go to
github.com to the ncbi organization and
the gaap tools repo
so the url you would go to is right here
and the first thing you take a look at
is the readme file
the readme file talks about how to get
gap tools running
on your local environment
the first thing you'll need is docker
installed
the next thing you'll need is to have
docker compose installed
and you'll also need access to your data
files if they're
local on
your host that you're going to be
running docker on you're fine if they're
located on s3 or gcs on the google cloud
platform
then you'll need to
essentially make those files locally
available to your docker host so we've
included some links here
for you to be able to go ahead and do
that
and the final prerequisite is to make
sure nothing on your computer is running
on port
8080
so to do that you take this command
run it on your host
and just make sure
nothing returns
in this case these connections are in
time weight and they're not actually
listening
if this were listening then that would
be a problem but since these are in time
weight they'll
go away soon and won't be a problem for
us
the next thing i want to go over is
before i go on to the setup is actually
the other readme file we have two
markdown files in here the other one is
called
gaaptools.md
and then this is a little more extensive
readme file
goes over what gap tools is it talks
about what is
been updated in the most recent version
why we're using docker to do this
the current quality control checks
at a very high level
and then uh the metadata file this is an
important piece of the puzzle you need
to specify a metadata file
and the uh called metadata.json and its
contents need to be structured like this
and this essentially tells
the validation pipeline where your files
are and what the file names are
additionally this talks about
how you check processing status
it shows the
validation pipeline
talks about all the checks in the
validation pipeline and at a high level
what the checks do
and it talks about the output files and
the results from the validation pipeline
and then we've included some sample
studies one without validation errors
and a few with validation errors
so we talk about and those are all based
on the thousand genomes project
so there's also a link
to what the thousand genomes project is
right there
so going back to the previous readme
file
and remember we've gone through our
prerequisites so we're good there
and then we go to our setup so the first
thing we do is clone the repository from
github
let's go ahead and do that
and then we
cd to the directory that just got
created when we
cloned the repository
the next step is we're going to make an
output directory
that we're going to use to output the
results from the validation pipeline
from our sample study
and then we're going to change the
permissions on that output directory to
make sure docker doesn't have a problem
writing to that output directory
that's it now we're all set up we're
ready to run the validation pipeline
so what we've included in this repo is a
bash script which essentially start uses
docker compose to start all the
necessary containers that run
the infrastructure for the validation
pipeline
there's some important switches here you
need to know
there's a dash i switch
this is the input directory where your
files are located
the o switch this is the output
directory
where you want the validation results to
go into
and the dash m switch
essentially is the metadata.json file
that i talked about earlier which says
where
are your specific files
what are their file names of the files
that are located in your input directory
so i'm going to go ahead and copy this
and paste it in here
and start that
script running
so again it's a docker compose script
what it does is it pulls down
the ncbi slash gap tools container which
has our validation pipeline in it
it also pulls down several other
containers to build the infrastructure
to run the validation pipeline
we use airflow
to run the validation pipeline so
essentially what this is doing is
building an airflow
infrastructure on your docker host
so it
pulls down
a database container
a key value store container
a flower container so you can view your
jobs
the airflow web container which is the
user interface into the airflow
infrastructure
a scheduler
airflow scheduler
the gap tools ui which is the ui into
the gap tools validation results
and then the airflow worker container
so once all those containers are pulled
down
then
begins to start the containers
it starts the database and all the
associated comp components around
airflow
it then
installs the validation pipeline into
airflow
as a as what uh airflow calls a dag a
distributed
graph
and then it initializes the database it
initializes airflow it brings all the
containers up and it makes sure that
everything is running correctly
so it uh checks every so often to make
sure
until the airflow web server is running
which is the final piece so it knows
once the airflow web server is running
then the infrastructure is good to go
and once the infrastructure is good to
go then it kicks off the validation
pipeline with the parameters you gave it
earlier
once this is done
it gives you where you can go to visit
the gap tools ui
and it also gives a command for what you
do when you're done with the containers
how to bring all those containers down
so i'm going to go ahead and go
into
the gap tools ui
there's an airflow web console link here
which takes you to the airflow web
console
and this is the validation pipeline
all these boxes are different tasks that
are run
to
validate the files that are part of your
submission
you can look at the status of each of
the tasks by looking at the color of the
line that's surrounding each task
if you hover over here under the success
you can see which tasks have been
completed successfully
the ones that are
highlighted in pink are ones that have
been skipped this particular study does
not have a pedigree file so all the
pedigree checks are skipped
and then the light green ones are the is
the task that's currently running
and then the ones that don't have a
status uh are
are uh there's no border around it or a
white border around it
so i'm gonna turn auto refresh back on
we can see that the validation pipeline
has completed so this once the
validation pipeline completes then now
we know that our validation results are
ready
so we go back to our main url
and under here
we see
the validation results
are right here there's a link
that you can click and it clicks to the
validation results we can see in this
particular study
the files processed have passed
and it gives you a link if you have any
uh need for any help you can click that
and email the db gap
sp help desk with any questions you have
you can see here there were zero files
with errors and three files with
warnings
the warnings this is a small study so
essentially the warnings are saying
there were insufficient x markers to
determine the subject's sex
and then there's also a validation
file that is produced called combined
one graph relationship
and i'll show you how to get to that in
just a minute
there's also a helpful link here that
you can go to
which
shows you all the validation errors that
could possibly occur and then a
description and the rule associated with
that error
so going back to
this email
these are the files that were analyzed
in the report and these are the files
that you've specified in your
metadata.json file
and then if you want to go back to the
home page you can go back to the home
page
so again in this
email there is this one file that's
produced that you can take a look at
you have to go into the
command line of your docker host
go to
the output directory
that you specified in your output
command line switch
and then in here you go to the geno
directory and then you go to the
graph relationship directory
and then you can see the file that was
produced as a result of this pipeline
and you can take a look at that file if
you like
so that is the
gap tools tool as it is today again a
good place to get started with this is
at github
slash ncbi slash gap tools
and oh one other thing i wanted to show
you was how to bring the
environment down go back to your
gaap tools
root directory of your github repo
and run
the dbgap docker dot bash command with
the with the down
argument afterwards
and that brings the environment down so
you don't have containers running on
your docker host that you don't need
anymore
so again so go to github.com
ncbi gap tools to get started with this
publicly available tool i appreciate you
taking the time to watch this
demonstration
and have a good day
thanks dale that was great um
uh
i think uh now we're at the the point in
this in the webinar where we can take
any and answer any questions yeah mike
do you want to show that slide uh the
the one at the end with the just uh help
desk stuff
so yeah mike we have some questions um
one of them was can you explain what the
subject consent file is
uh yes the subject consent file is in
its very simple form it's a three column
table um the first column is the subject
id of each uh
study participant
the consent for that subject is the
second column and then
the third column is the sex of the
individual
okay that's that sounds good thank you
um
a specific question can the subject id
be the same as a sample id
yes that is allowed in dbgap
we allow you that we allow the subject
and sample id to be the same although we
treat those as two separate
numbering spaces
okay thanks mike
another question is dbgap still
accepting large batches of exome and
genome data or just genotypes at this
point
uh right now the the gap tools operates
on um
called
genotypes from either exo merge or or
whole whole whole genome
but in the future we plan to to expand
it out there is no
there's no um
plans to extend this to the actual
sequence
files like a bam file or anything like
that right now um the sra team
has has some tools to do that so we're
not planning to do that right now
and somebody asked the question about
the gap tools in doctor
dale answered it but i'll just
restate it um
that you don't need to have the sequence
files but this is just to validate the
metadata that's correct mike
yeah that's right um the the tool will
operate on
any subset of the files it does require
the subject consent file though that is
a required file but any other files if
you want to just check the subject
consent to the phenotypes you can do
that if you want to check the
ssm to the subject consent file you can
do that
you know one of the questions is you
know do you absolutely need gaap tools
and the answer to that i think is no you
don't have to use it it's just to help
you make sure that your submission goes
more smoothly correct
yeah that's right um one one of the
reasons we wanted to present this as a
webinar is just to make people aware of
this um some of the some of the people
on the webinar
are
nih officials that that
are
managing the registration and and the
submission of the data
um
and others are our submitters we
because we run the tool internally
a lot of users
don't
need to know anything about
running the docker
version
but
there are a fair number of submitters
that submit
frequently or
have have
multiple submissions that might want to
run this tool
on their own the other use could be a
parallel resource that are
managing similar data that might want to
also run these type of checks
it does require the dbgap formatted
files
which is a relational model so hopefully
that wouldn't be too burdensome
yeah so i mean couple people have
commented on that so it should help with
your submission process um back to the
question that was about the submissions
of the exome sequences
i think you answered the question about
gaap tools not being a part of the
you know submission of those kinds of
data just genotypes
i guess the question is are you still
accepting um wgs data is there a
capacity issue and accepting these kinds
of data
no actually that the capacity issue has
been largely mitigated
namely because
a lot of the data in dbgap
or
available
through access in dbgap
is is actually hosted now on on on the
cloud by uh
some federated um storage
solutions that we that the nih has has
developed
and so
submissions directly to the sra
um
if they're if they're massive petabyte
scale we
definitely want to know about those
before you submit them
but
a lot of the issues that
existed in the past about the storage
space um at ncbi have have been
mitigated
hopefully that answers the question
um one question that came up was someone
was asking um
what kind of computer gap tools can run
on and dale i think
we both answered that question in two
different ways so you were running that
on the cloud correct
uh yeah it was uh
ubuntu server on the in the cloud so
yeah i was just getting a little more
specific for um that question
is it available and does it run on other
platforms besides linux
yes
so essentially anything that runs docker
will be able to run this tool
so that related to docker somebody asked
about any experience with a singularity
create container created from docker do
we have any experience with that
uh
well we looked we looked into that um
but we have not
tested that and uh as in its current
form we don't think it will work um but
that that is something
uh that we uh
may
dig into further in the future yeah and
if you're interested in uh this
singularity version of this um i think
we need to hear from you um
we get enough requests we might we might
bump this up in priority
so here's a question that that might be
a way to sort of summarize how gaap
tools might help a person says that
they're going to be
submitting data for gywa study in the
next year or so and have only one
previous dbgap submission but have not
used gap tools what's the advantage for
me to learn to use gap tools versus
submitting without it
uh well i think like i said uh if if you
have uh one of one or two submissions
it's probably not something that you
want to run um
as the standalone version but knowing
that it exists and there'll be an
automated
processing of the data once it's
submitted is
hopefully
helpful
okay mike i think
i think i want to wrap this up uh right
now and what i think we'll do is there
are lots of questions in the question
squad that are highly specific and
detailed
we're going to get these into a document
materials in that document we'll put
that up there as soon as we have it
ready so we'll have all these questions
answered for everybody
okay that sounds great and i do want to
thank everybody
for for taking time out of out of their
day to to join today thank you
all right i'll go ahead and end the
webinar for everybody